all right my name is Tom Mock I'm the
product manager for our studio and posit
workbench been a lot of talk about posit
workbench today so that's been great uh
I'm here with a basically a one- slide
presentation which is GitHub co-pilot is
available in our studio and it's finally
here okay so we have a couple more
slides because we'll want to talk about
it but this talk officially closed is
issue
1048 can we have GitHub co-pilot
integration with our studio which is by
far the most requested feature of all
time in our studio with about 519
upvotes but we don't want to stop there
in terms of just because it's available
doesn't mean it's the most useful uh
tool or you need to know how to use it
to get the most out of it so that's what
I'll spend today talking about to really
understand what co-pilot is I first want
to just briefly mention the idea of
generative AI which is a tool that's
designed to create novel or new content
right so it's been trained to identify
patterns and then generate new outcomes
based upon them for today's talk I was
playing around with mid Journey which is
another uh tool with generative AI for
creating images and so I created my own
little co-pilot here uh my dog Howard
who's always with me as I'm programming
in my home and you see the prompt I used
was actually about 15 words or so and it
came out with this remarkably novel
output in terms of an image that's
fairly complex I could not probably
describe this image in 15 words but I
was able to create this image in 15
words so co-pilot is a tool with
generative AI to do similar things but
with code so co-pilot is kind of
autocomplete style suggestions as ghost
text available inside our
studio now I want to differentiate a
little bit here though you already have
autocomplete available inside our studio
right so you have autocomplete that will
parch the code and the environment
and importantly it's applying possible
completions right it has to have some
text and it's finishing the word for you
so this is a static set of completions
and little popup and it's provided from
your IDE from your local disc or your
local
environment so co-pilot can also provide
autocomplete style suggestions as ghost
text and I'll show that in a second but
let's differentiate a little bit here so
co-pilot yes it'll parse the code it
parse the environment but it also has
billions of examples of code in the
training data of how other people have
approached coding problems so it can
supply likely completions they don't
even have to be possible or present in
your environment but the likely
completion of it and these uh Dynamic
set of completions it's providing are
available via ghost text so it's not
just that one little snippet you're
completing but it could be a multi-line
or an entire function that you're
defining and importantly it is a
generative AI tool and it's provided via
an API endpoint that you're quering and
getting back into your IDE
so let's do this visually we like
Graphics we like images so here's
autocomplete inside our studio I'm
autocom completing the word mean and I
have a couple different variations of
mean that I can complete here great this
works fantastic in our studio but if you
notice I have a comment earlier in my
script saying take the mean of the mpg
column in mp Mt cars data set I've
already said what I want to do so why
don't I just get the average of the Mt
cars data set in the G column so here
co-pilot is providing post text
completion and it's actually parsing
that comment and doing a prediction of
what it thinks I want to get out of this
so my intent has been codified into a
comment which is then reflected in an
output but we can go a lot farther than
that maybe I want to do a group by
summarize so I can have a comment saying
calculate the average fuel fuel
efficiency of cars grouped by cylinder
and
lowlier so now I have context that
includes the comment and that I've
loaded a library let's use that library
to do something I get co-pilot generated
ghost text that's multiple lines not
just one word and importantly this ghost
text doesn't exist in the IDE yet it's
just a UI element and I can choose to
accept it if I don't like that output
I'll back it out and try again add some
more context go
forward so you can be really powerful
with this you can codify more of your
intent into the document and be more
productive and we'll go into some more
advanced examples but I've only been
using screenshots and I at least want to
show one little video of what this looks
like in practice it's going to be fast
but just we'll watch it
together I'm speeding up my development
process here three lines of function I
made mode it's very simple but I can
move forward with it and use it almost
immediately and it's really at the speed
of
autocompletion so again I provided a
little bit of context in the script I
provided a scoped and specific prompt
which is return a function to calculate
the mode of a vector it defines a
multi-line function for me I can use
that and then I can immediately use it
in my script I also want to call out the
three the status of the request at the
bottom of the ID saying co-pilot is
communicating or it's finished sending
me back a response so we're going to
build off this idea of sure can generate
ghost Tex can be single line multi-line
and we'll go into a bit more of a
complicated example if you want to get
started with co-pilot in our studio
importantly you do have to have a
subscription to co-pilot so you can go
to GitHub get a personal subscription or
you can get it through your inter PR for
business in the upcoming release of our
studio and workbench uh which we're
expecting in September uh you'll be able
to enable this within the IDE or you can
try it in the dailies that are available
right now so you go to tools Global
options co-pilot tab you go to sign in
it takes you to a prompt you sign into
to GitHub and then you're signed in as
your user in this case I'm Jay Thomas
mock on GitHub I'm signed in and can use
co-pilot now that I've got co-pilot
available on my IDE and I want to get
you know started I think the most
important thing you can do with any
brand new tool is play around with it
don't just use something basic don't
necessarily try to use it in production
but play around with something and try
and break it try and see where it works
for you and where it doesn't I like a
game called keyword this is something my
family started playing it's similar to
like Wordle but it's like a mini
crossword puzzle that um you can play on
your phone and we could do it as a
family it looks a little bit like this
so a miniature cross word but there's no
hints all you're trying to do is fill
the word across horizontally and in this
case the word is felony and the
horizontal uh word is felony and then
each of those letters spell a different
word so how can we solve the keyword
game I can sit there I can try and
figure out what the letters are or
because I'm doing a conference talk I
can say let's try and solve this with r
our studio and co-pilot and see how far
we can get that's exactly what I did I
played around with it went through for
about an hour prompting trying to see
how far co-pilot could take me with me
doing as minimal coding as possible
now to do this I had to get the most out
of the generative Loop and I want y'all
to also get the most out of the
generative Loop right like co-pilot is
just a generative AI tool it doesn't
have intelligence it doesn't really know
anything it's just a prediction engine
so the more context and the more of our
intent we can write down the better
predictions it's going to give us that
context is like what prompts have been
provided what source code is there um
what packages are loaded what's in your
environment kind of all this metadata
that you can provide which is quite
different than the intent which is what
I actually want to do so again I'm
trying to codify my intent into a prompt
that I can get a response back from and
then there's the output that co-pilot
actually returns which hopefully is
close to my intent which was provided by
the context so in this case I'm going to
show you a few ways to do better context
to get you closer to what you actually
want to do with your intent and get
overall a better
output and my little buzzword for what
we'll use for today is called S2 see for
simple specific and use comments and I
mean use comments throughout inline big
comments all over the place and simplify
and break up your problems into specific
parts so again we're trying to solve
keyword which is a pretty open-ended
problem to solve with a programming
language so we going to break down the
task give it a overall structure what
are we going to do moving forward I know
how to play keyword but now I have to
teach co-pilot or teach R to play
co-pilot although I know other people
have solved games like word with our
already so I know it's possible I wred a
bunch of comments I'm not trying to get
code back yet I'm just writing down for
both myself and for C- pilot as a prompt
what am I trying to do I'm trying to
solve the keyword game I talk about how
to play the game and provide a little
bit of context again this is not really
talking anything about R this is just
background right I'm I'm not saying
write this function but we're going to
create a function
ultimately so I take that context and
then I move down my script and start
adding a little bit more again I want to
break down this complex task of solve
keyword into something more simple the
simplest method is to not cheat but be
clever so I know that this is a web
portal it is a Json API that's available
so I can get the Json blob from behind
the scenes and I get the answer from
that so co-pilot has solved it and we're
done for the day the answer is staple
for August
9th well that's cheating and I don't
really want to cheat I want to show you
how cool co-pilot is inside our studio
so what else is in there we actually
have the words or the hints that are
provided so that's something unique I
can provide those hints to R to our
studio to copilot and we can move
forward and try and solve each of the
individual words to make up the larger
word and if I fill in those with staple
I get C chant bear spur really scale so
we kind of know where we're trying to go
with this simpler problem as we move
forward so we're just going to get the
hint words breaking down into the
component parts and working with those
now I've provided a little bit longer
prompt so six lines of comments and then
I say I'm basically trying to get that
URL for any specific date right I don't
want to have to manually type in the
date I can do like today's date CIS date
and here I'm getting a function back
that takes the date glues it together
returns me a URL that I can use to get
these uh hints every single time so then
I can move forward with using those
outputs and those words moving
forward so now that I've got the the
hint words I can save those into an
object and then I get them back out and
be like all right now I can actually
start working with these hints in R and
I'm not cheating anymore I'm
programming now while that was a lot of
comments I can also do expressive Nam so
if I have comments and say oh well this
is what I'm actually trying to do and
name it so the variable the function the
objects I'm working with this will help
provide additional context about what
I'm trying to do so here I only have two
comments and I start typing reject and
it returns back a Rex from the input
word in this case replacing any
underscore with a AZ match so it'll
replace it with any lowercase letter
again I've provided only minimal
comments and I'm just starting to use
more expressive names to go along with
those comments and getting back a nice
output of what I actually want and then
I can apply that Rex from word so I can
say oh well given that let's do matched
words no comments but just by using what
are the match words as the expressive
name now it's saying oh well we'll we'll
subset limit the words in get the reject
ply those together and these are the
words from my little database of words I
have locally that are four units long
and could possibly match what's your
missing letters but no comments just by
using expressive names and the
additional context from within the
document and again we can get a little
bit longer and by saying I want the top
words and doing a little bit more
comments now we have about 12 or 15
lines I think of code that it's
generating a longer function that's
using that matched words we used
previously uh applying it splitting it
out into characters scoring the letters
to say oh these letters or higher value
uh setting those to the name sorting it
and then putting out the top so I'm not
really worried about what the code is
it's functional it's working but I'm
just trying to see okay how far can we
get I've got a lot of momentum going
forward I'm really excited let's keep
going and then without any comments I
can say well give me just the letters
from the blank and it gives me a feline
function to get that out
so again as you build up your script and
as you add more context into co-pilot it
will give you a better content out so
you get a better
output ultimately rather than showing
you how to solve keyword we did
eventually get to keyword so I can say
from September 9th a month after I
started trying to do this um I can get
the keyword as one of the following
words recipe or repipe and as much as I
love pipes as a tidyverse user I don't
really know if repipe is a word um so
I'm I'm going to go with its recipes
which is a wonderful tidy models package
and we'll accept that so there you go
Maxon ultimately I want to show you a
couple things that you can look at after
the fact there's a gist with the full um
transcript of me prompting trying to say
do this do that give me this get back
and you can look at it it's a couple
hundred lines of me exploring and then
the keyword function if you really are
interested and want to impress your
family and solve keyword in about 2
seconds every single
day now while this was fun and like we
went through and solved a complex
problem you're going to get stuck and I
got stuck and had to interject myself in
the middle at certain points so again
what you're trying to do to get yourself
unstuck is add more context and again
follow
s2c simple specific and use comments
break up your problem into simpler
problems solving a specific task that
are well commented you can also try
prompting again or in a different way so
rather than just trying to get a
function back you could have an inline
com comment of an existing function that
you're trying to expand adding new
arguments or expanding it in a different
way and again more comments more top
level comments more inline comments more
comments throughout even in the middle
of a deep lier pipeline you can add a
comment to have it do a mutate step to
specifically add something in there and
then ultimately you're trying to build
off your own momentum as my script got
longer and as I got closer to solving my
problem co-pilot was actually doing a
much better job with the context it was
getting from my script and ultimately WR
of your own code you know this is not
going to replace who you are as a
programmer it's going to expand your
skills or make you a bit faster so
solving a problem in an hour as opposed
to me just kind of searching around
trying to find examples and then
spending a whole day or two on
it so we talked a lot about co-pilot but
I've got Ed Edgar Ruiz here so I do want
to do a call out to say that there's
more than one way to generate text
there's ghost text which is really cool
it's co-pilot it's in our studio but
maybe I want to chat with somebody maybe
I want to do chat GPT style so Edgar has
a package called chatter through the MLV
group here at posit and you can actually
run a open AI chat interface or other
local um models like llama on your
laptop and communicate with them through
our studio in the viewer pane so the
Chatter app is what this basically is
and it can allow you to connect to a lot
of different
models now inside of our studio proper
number one great logo chatter is awesome
you can call the chatter Chatter app and
you can pop it into our studio or you
can run it as a background job to leave
your console free so that you can
interact with it but in short it'll just
be in your little viewer Pane and you
can interact with it and ask more
open-ended questions but it's not even
that basic like it really is essentially
chat GPT running inside of our studio in
this example but what Edgar has done
here and what they what's really
exciting is the prompt is pre-populated
with useful things so if you look at
this and I don't want you to read it all
because it's too much but there's like
20 lines of text in here of enriched
information so when you actually go to
your prompt it already has amazing
amounts of context to help your
responses be better for the task at hand
which is probably our programming
although you can always customize this
we've uh provided nice defaults but you
can customize it modify it and make it
behave a bit more like you want it to so
ultimately this is more of what you're
doing with a chat style interface is
you're asking a question but your
question also has some enrichments that
chatter does like saying oh there's
files in the environment there's data
frame names in the environment there's
additional prompts that we're providing
and it has the history of the discussion
so far and this is submitted to the
model and you get a response back in the
IDE and happy healthy you can ask it
questions as well as get your co-pilot
results in the
IDE so ultimately this was a wild run
through keyword and solving problems
with co-pilot our studio studio just
showing you a few different ways of you
can use them inside workbench in our
studio again for the best outputs at
least with co-pilot you want to do these
simple specific use comments to be
productive co-pilot is available as an
optional integration it's available as a
preview feature and our upcoming 20230
relase .09 release of our studio and
workbench and if you want to provide
feedback or report bugs about this
feature please open a GitHub issue on a
repo and we'll make improvements through
that uh for chatter you can install it
from GitHub as well so remotes install
GitHub mlvs chatter and you can use it
again with open AI um endpoints some
other endpoints that are available via
API interfaces or open source models
running on your local laptop like llama
so ultimately whether you are a cat
person a dog person or you like todoro
there's a generative AI tool out there
that you can use in our studio be
productive and you can have your own
little co-pilot that'll work with you so
thank you for your time and I have some
time for
[Applause]
[Music]
questions yes thank you Tom thank you
for that awesome presentation um very
excited about this and we definitely
have a lot of questions and in fact I
never seen this room so full so I'm
excited and a little bit nervous at this
point all right so um the question is
and this is connected to the co-pilot
thing uh has there been any special
tuning training done to optimize the
co-pilot uh for R gotcha yeah so
co-pilot is a third party integration
fully absolutely so it's been trained on
uh I want to say several billion uh
examples of code uh so it is uh
available for R python SQL JavaScript
all sorts of different things it's not
necessarily optimized for r or for
python or for SQL it kind of whatever
examples were fed into that model are
what it's good at um I found it
remarkably good for specific task R um
if you're trying to do data manipulation
pipelines pretty good if you're trying
to get a 20 line data analysis script it
might kind of hallucinate or send you in
a Direction that's a bit odd if you're
trying to do too broad of a problem that
it's solving but for these programming
tasks writing functions turning um
repeated things into functions adding
little steps into your mutate pipeline
remarkably good and again good at
capturing my intent and putting it into
an output thank you um the next question
says what elements of your R environment
are being sent to co-pilot all the text
in the script contents of objects in the
environment something more yeah so
there's an option you can have it
limited to only the file at hand so the
script you're working on or you can
actually have it index additional files
in your project that's really helpful
when you're working on say like a
multifile application or you have
multiple uh you know sourcing files from
external files right or sourcing
functions from external files so you can
have it get that in the prompt as well
well so it's controllable um but it's
reading primarily from the script at
hand in additional files possible thank
you uh the next question says how do I
avoid flinging key material into the
cloud via the co-pilot API yeah
absolutely so again optional integration
there's like six steps you have to go to
to even opt into this which is buy
subscription uh opt in install something
and then sign in um again we're setting
up some things where you can have it
focus on only the file at hand so if you
have sensitive information in other
files you don't open them there you can
also turn it on and off really quickly
so with the command pallet in our studio
command shift p or control shift p you
can turn it on and off immediately if
you're like switching between an open
kind of script in one where you don't
want to send that
out thank you so next question says uh
can I use one co-pilot license with our
studio and other IDs for example vs code
absolutely yeah there's nothing that
we're doing to limit that access so you
should be able to use your login I used
it for vs code as well as for our studio
with my personal account yeah great um I
think we have time for one more question
does co-pilot work with within notebook
chunks and know which language you are
using yes you can use it inside Cordo uh
Source mode um and I actually am writing
up in some of the documentation how you
can do things in the body of a document
where you can actually include HTML or
JavaScript and then when you go into a
code chunk it is indicating this is r or
it's python or SQL or whatever um there
are times where it kind of thinks the
wrong thing and it gives the wrong
prediction uh but most of the time it
was accurate to say oh this is R this is
python or this is SQL but you can always
give it more context saying python chunk
our chunk if it's giving you the wrong
outputs so thank you so much thank you
again appreciate it thank you
[Applause]
Tom